[Music]  tell me the fairy tale again it's too  scary you know start seeing things that  aren't there  [Music]  you've been turned out of your home it's  a toss of them for yourselves with only  your clothes in your hides  I'm hungry I'm hungry then you are total  a pig it's no cake  careful for that dia I'd hate for you to  start something you can't stop please  make your acquaintance I'm called Gretel  miss rough one here is my brother Hansel  something wrong here it's so pleasant  where are all the animals and where does  she draw milk mrs. stone  this is your power to see what has  hidden him to take way hurt if necessary  death assume magic Ricky Joyce have  others whose left used to make  [Music]  [Music]